and as bill just mentioned hundreds of
thousands of californians are trying to
recall gascon but they're not the only
ones calling out da's abuses just last
week an appeals court affirmed gascon
overstated his authority when he refused
to enforce the state's three strikes law
chris landau argued the case before the
california court of appeals and he joins
us now chris
um why is this important now
laura it's important because it's cl
important for these das to know that
they have to follow the rule of law too
and it gives an important civics lesson
they say that well
we were elected and we don't want to
prosecute these laws but the executive
branch has an obligation to enforce the
law that's basic civics now people don't
understand this but he was actually sued
by
his
own staff right his own it's a big
office obviously but they were unhappy
that's actually that's absolutely
correct laura and it's really remarkable
those were my clients and they you know
are the men and women who every day have
to go into court and say i'm here on
behalf of the people of california they
were told by their boss by d.a gascon
not to enforce the law they were told
not to plead the the prior strikes that
are necessary for the operation of the
three strikes law and that's why
the organization of assistant da's in
gascon's office hired us and we brought
this lawsuit and the court just
vindicated our theory that that would
violate the law now gascon has
spoken a lot about rising crime in los
angeles and he said this recently watch
we know that the numbers are even higher
in some of the jurisdictions that are
being uh you know that are being
administered by very uh right-wing uh
district attorneys and police chiefs
unless we address the root causes of
crime
unless we look at the issues of mental
health we look at the issues of
substance abuse we look at the issues of
homelessness we look at the income
inequality system and racism unless we
address all things we're going to
continue to see crime increases in many
parts of the country
chris i'm listening to him and he sounds
like a congressman like he's making a
legislative argument against harsh
penalties absolutely laura no sooner had
he gotten into office in december of
2020 he issued a number of directives to
his staff openly saying i disagree with
the three strikes law
but that's the role of the legislature
of course it is
he's supposed to fulfill the law as it's
written correct and that's what's so
important about this lawsuit laura that
again it's basic civics the legislature
determines the law if the legislature
says the the the penalty for a
particular crime the sentence is between
20 and 30 years a prosecutor can't go in
and seek either 10 or 40 right i mean
you the legend the prosecutor has to
operate within the bounds of the law and
he instructed his staff not to do so
separate issues supreme court leak you
and i both clerk for justice thomas
different years
how important is it to find out who
leaked that draft opinion it is
essential laura i hope and pray that
this doesn't become one of those
washington
uh leak things that just goes on for
years and then people kind of forget
about it i mean this is important to the
integrity of the supreme court united
states this has never happened in
history that a draft opinion has leaked
the pool of potential leakers is very
small very small right it's a clerk it's
not a justice you would think it's a
just knowledge no and i i so again i i
think that this is inconceivable that
this has not already been resolved would
this have happened under rehnquist
no
no
listen laura i mean the times have
changed but you know again i think it's
important for the court that this be
done professionally and quickly and fast
like a month ago yes yes yes get them
all in the room
figure it out all right chris great to
see you congrats on the huge win for you
and your law firm well thank you laura
and listen this guy you know i think a
murderer had uh gascon's name tattooed
on his face so i think if the if the
murderers are tattooing the da's name on
their face you know you've got a problem
there great work chris thank you so much
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else